i'm fascinated with your comedy before
you were married to after you were
married and then with kids and um and
the fact that you would just like make
stuff up
before you were married because nobody
was gonna know right you can make up
about a girl and it don't matter
right you clearly can't because you're
married now
and my act they had like 90 x y's
um so
well first off have you ever made a joke
about me
have i made a joke about danica patrick
you know what i think i did i think uh
i what did i say yeah i said that uh
danica patrick i go holy smokes she's
good i said she's good look and now all
the nascar drivers are going to have to
have windshield wipers on the inside of
the car
and
then
what was in this i think another one is
about pull pull setter but i can't
remember how it went
that's a good one on the pole danica's
on the pole again
yeah i think it was i think no i never
did that when it was something about
pull setter but it was for i think it
was i can't remember what it was for it
was
i can't remember so long ago
but i think i only did two or three of
them i'll tell you a funny story though
remember when we went down to
you and i
were like you were the grand marshal and
i was also doing something we were the
two big guests at the big place
uh louisiana i think it was
or no it was at the football game
yeah yeah yeah it was like a great that
probably wouldn't have been able to but
it was a bowl game that's right was it
in mobile alabama
yeah it was yeah and it was funny
because you and i were kind of hanging
out and then you went up you went up did
your deal then i mean you said a couple
of jokes about me and then i went up and
did my deal then a couple of natick
patrick jokes i think one of them might
have been windshield wipes on the inside
and anyway and then
they they said some interviewed me but
we both said something nice about each
other and i just thought this was so
funny i was cleaning out my mail the
other day and i have stuff all the way
back from 2012 so i'm just getting rid
of stuff and i come across an article
from that thing
and it was some gossip column
in hollywood and it said
it said
could there be a new romance in the
making
and it said
and it said the chemistry between danica
patrick
and i was i was like oh my gosh i don't
even remember this article i showed my
wife and we just got into laughing about
it it was so hilarious that's amazing
i'm sure your wife has a good sense of
humor herself oh
comedian but i'm so cute so
what would be an example like was there
some certain jokes before you were
married that would just like bring the
house down
that were total lies
oh my gosh absolutely or maybe based on
truth maybe
maybe just a small nugget of truth a
small nugget
but i would go yeah milo
you know these are so far back
i'm trying to remember i've had like are
you larry are you larry in these jokes
oh yeah if
i could if i can remember them
i'm trying to think if i can remember
from way back then now you're talking
about my first album that literally was
from like to
1999 or 2000
um i'm trying to remember some of those
jokes about yeah i dated this gal
uh
she had one boot bigger than the other
boob we got wet t-shirt going down she
took first third place on that damn
thing and i told her
you know there's all kind i can't
remember that far back um uh
yeah mike what was one uh yeah my
sister-in-law
my sister-in-law got married last week
and
now she's pregnant she didn't tell her
husband
she didn't even tell her husband that
she was pregnant because he kind of
gotten used to or thrown up after they
had sex now so they can't
you know
but everything i made up all kinds of i
made up brothers i made up sisters i
made up
see that was the cool thing about back
then it was so freeing i mean i could
make up family members and and and
all that stuff and i had kind of did
have a little dilemma because when i got
married
i thought oh man
i don't want to be doing i'm out with
this girl last night or i was at the
strip club last week or i was you know
because that was like well
even if it's made up i don't want to
because i'm married now so i don't want
people going
and we've already established from the
very beginning that you're a very kind
guy and that you like people to feel
comfortable so the last thing you want
to do is make your wife feel like she's
not important or not oh my gosh
i literally had to get rid of anything
like that i didn't do i did
ex-girlfriend jokes
i didn't do ex-wife jokes anymore
because everybody knew this was my first
wife
in real life and that's that was the
first time though danica that was really
weird for me because that was the first
time that the character
blended in with me with my real life
before
everything was fake